but I will say one other thing speaking
of indictments in Donald Trump and
criminal charges and all that new polls
have come out this week multiple new
polls showing that the indictment from
last week is not helping Donald Trump at
all
now shortly after the indictment about a
day or two later Donald Trump got on
Truth social and uh you know attacked
the prosecutors as he's been doing but
he also mentioned in one of those posts
on true socials my poll numbers have
gone through the roof
and to an extent with the Republican
base they absolutely have
but if you're just going to cherry pick
the data then sure you can pretty much
use it to prove whatever you want to
prove so you got to look at the bigger
picture which is something Donald Trump
doesn't want people to do because his
approval rating
ever since those indictments came down
has tanked Four Points dropping from an
already historically low 29 percent
all the way down to 25
according to a new ABC News ipsos poll
but what's more important with this
polling data along with other polling
data that recently came out from CNN
is that Independence are the ones
who have effectively turned against
Donald Trump let me read some of these
numbers for you here
according to the ABC poll 54 of
Independents say that Trump should have
been charged with a crime
57 percent
say that he intentionally did something
illegal
now it is a little weird that those two
numbers are not equal which means you
have more people more independent saying
yes he definitely did something illegal
and he did it illegal on purpose
but you only have 54 percent that say he
should have been charged so there's a
three a three percent Gap there that
makes no sense so three percent of
Independents think oh yeah he totally
intentionally broke the law but he
shouldn't be charged so that's a little
weird again you would expect those
numbers to match up but they don't but
either way you have a majority of
independent voters and that's the key
that do believe not only that Trump
should have been charged but that he
definitely intentionally did something
illegal
the CNN numbers are even worse for Trump
62 percent of Independents in the CNN
poll approve of the indictment
of course Democrats uh Democrats I don't
know why I said that awkward the
Democrats overwhelmingly support it
Republicans overwhelmingly reject it
so what does this matter right Trump's
approval rating goes down four points
obviously very bad for him as he tries
to run for president
but it's the numbers with the
Independence that are important
because yes Trump's poll numbers within
the Republican Party they're doing great
they're doing better than they have in
the last year
the problem Trump faces is that he
hasn't attracted any new voters
and that's the key
see Trump cannot win a general election
with just his Maga base he can win a
primary with it hundred percent like no
question about that and right now based
on the numbers looks like he may be
cruising to an easy Victory with that
but when it comes time for the general
election
he's repulsed
the independence he's repulsed the
moderate Republicans
right-wing groups have already been
holding focus groups
since the indictments came down
and sure there's plenty of them who say
nope this has actually made me more
likely to vote for Trump but some
Republicans say this sealed the deal I'm
not going to support him
so even the people who came back to
support Trump after saying no I'm done
with him wait no I'm going to come back
those aren't new Trump voters those are
previous Trump voters
who are just coming back into the fold
so they voted for him in the past and
now they're saying they're going to vote
for him again so that doesn't count as a
new gain for Trump that's why these
numbers are important we have to fully
analyze them and realize what they're
telling us and right now they're telling
us that those true moderates The
Independents the swing voters out there
in America
they want nothing to do with this guy
they're sick of it
they're saying he's too caustic
he's too bombastic he's got too much
baggage
I mean he's not due back in court until
December
but under New York state law the
prosecution has to be ready to go to
trial within six months of issuing the
indictments
so even though he's not due back till
December at that point the prosecution
legally has to be ready to go
so we could get a trial during the
Republican primary we could get a trial
before
the 2024 election
and that's not going to play well with
those moderates and independents because
we're also talking about a New York jury
Donald Trump is not well liked up there
so he doesn't stand a very good chance
of being successful maybe on appeal but
probably not with initial trial
and The Independents are already sick of
them they're ready for him to go away
his poll numbers continue to get worse
no matter what he says
he's in trouble and he knows it
we have to take a quick break I am fair
and cousins you can follow me on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook I'm at fair and
balanced and subscribe to the ring of
fire YouTube channel youtube.com the
ring of fire we'll be right back with
more on the David packman show one of
our sponsors is betterhelp I am a huge
believer in therapy let's say you've
been thinking for a while about getting
into therapy you know it's the right
move you have things you'd like to talk
to someone about there is no better time
than the present but you don't have to
drive across town every week and sit in
a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists specializing in a wide range
of issues you answer a few questions
about yourself and better help will
match you with a therapist based on your
specific needs and preferences the
sessions can be on the phone video call
chat anytime anywhere from your couch at
home from your office at work and if
your therapist isn't the right fit you
can switch anytime at no charge my
audience gets 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below